I'm also not a fan of the people that
hit people in the nuts for laughs no I
got hit in the nuts the only time that
was a good time to get hit in the nuts
was by Johnny Knoxville
I felt like I was hit by anyone in the
nuts
it'll be Johnny not yo but yeah hitting
in the nuts that's not like fact at
that's what I'm saying I've been on sets
of other people shows and they're like
we're real typeset real tight crew we
love Murano oh really what do you mean
they just tap each other in the nuts
because a light tap hurts more than a
direct auto it cuz it's like yeah it's a
dull ache it's a dull ache if it comes
in like the tide I just remembered who
it was who it was the cast of Mad Men
wait that hit people in the balls hams
doing it guess what guess what no one is
doing do it hidden ham in the know
course no one's hitting ham balls I'm
not I'm not injured through there's a
movie called Get Carter Michael Caine is
in it where he's naked and has a full-on
fighting in the nude hole like that
uncomfortable makes me uncomfortable
there's another movie like in video says
yes I don't like that yeah yeah that
makes Emma good the balls are out like
you see up his crack - oh yeah I mean
that you see everything in that that
fights it's happening but I will say
this yeah Viggo's got a cherry chase -
yeah they're all dead I mean if you're
gonna do a nude fight so you need a
championship any gonna give it you're
gonna get up high but here's my thought
wait I got it and you gotta wake it up a
little but I mean there are gay people
to wake that law like this is a fight
thing that probably took like two or
three days - yeah yeah yeah all day VI
come on come on
maybe then that's where the sack tab
comes in you need people to kind of keep
on hitting here to invigorate a guy
there what's a fluffer a fluffer keeps
you hard on a porn set so what is that
that person is not sack tapping right
now it's it's like a erotic woman oh
really yeah you go over like so it's
basically sort of like some union guy
but really
there you go here you go he did it they
worked my head out but is she less
attractive than the woman and boy like
these monster women are yeah I'm doing
with my hands and mouth but I always
wanna come best any jobs in the land but
this bases get me off camera this face
will keep you just on the brink how sad
would that be to be like yeah I'm a
fluffer but here's the thing yes the way
that a stand-up comedian will take a
warm-up gig to warm up a TV audience
I should go porn star will take a
fluffing gig you think that there's like
there's upward mobility in the fluffy
yeah I just need a couple extra bucks do
you like the way you like hey I'm gonna
say thank you so much Paul check out
Paul Scheer in all his various and
wonderful private property ah thanks for
being here